All right, folks, welcome back.
It feels just like yesterday, the last time we'd spoke.
All right, so here we have one of those instances where, as luck would have it, the hands of
fate, the planets aligned, all those factors came in on something I gave you in an analysis
last night.
Now, before you start snickering and rolling your eyes and sending your husband up to slap
me on the stage, just understand that this is just one piece, one little piece of price
action in the delivery that the algorithm will likely, not every single instance, but
it will likely repeat.
Okay, it's the logic that I've shared on this YouTube channel, and I've been asked
obviously, if you read the comments in the videos, can I show an example of this working
in London Session for Forex?
No problem.
To do that, I set the stage with the analysis last night.
There are folks out there that will say, I don't know how to pick the tops and the bottoms
or the highs and the lows of the day.
They don't know what I'm teaching, so it's easy for them to say those types of things.
A new student may stumble upon their comment, may stumble upon their YouTube channel, and
whatever their medium is, they follow that logic without investigating it or looking
into whether or not these things that I claim are true.
So without a safety net last night, I outlined it for you, I explained what it should do,
why it should take place, and therefore, we watch.
And do I see in my chart, like you should see in yours, what I outlined?
Not exactly to the level I was outlining, but the general premise was there.
What do I mean by that?
Well, we were in this area here, and I mentioned that I felt that it was going to go below
the 100 level, and if I were making the market, in other words, if I was the market maker,
providing the parameters at which the dollar index will go down to set up a buying opportunity,
I would take it down to the 99.92 level.
And you can check me on that with the video I uploaded, and I can't edit a video on YouTube.
Once it's there, it's there.
So some of you are actually downloading them, that's fine, but go to episode 19, which is
the one I just did last night, and listen to the 20 minute mark around the 10 second
net vicinity, and let it play for a minute or so, and you'll hear me outline the very
thing that you're seeing in your chart right now.
So the question is going to be, how did I know to call that level, and why did I know
that it was likely to set up a London setup?
Well, I'm going to teach that to you tonight.
So understand that this is not the model for my daughter, this is not in addition to
the model, I'm just simply answering questions, because I got a lot of them, and I'm not trying
to push this inside of the model for this YouTube mentorship, because the next step
is going to be, can you go into London and do live sessions so we can copy what you're
doing?
I'm not going to do that, okay?
Now, some of you are going to be upset and say, oh, well, see, you're not proving anything.
Well, if you're not seeing this as proof, move along, okay?
Just move along.
I'm only going to do what I'm willing to do, okay?
And I'm having fun showing what I'm showing, and it's really enough.
Only those individuals that want to be spoon-fed setups and trades and piggyback my ideas,
they're the only ones that really push and twist my arm, and they're going to be frustrated.
So I'm just letting you know, that's not going to happen.
So don't ask.
I don't care how many times you present it nicely in a comment or request, it's simply
not going to happen.
It's important for you to go in and find these setups on your own using what I'm teaching.
So I mentioned that we would drop below that 100 level.
Why did I pick the 99.92 level?
Okay, well, if you look at the price action right over here, okay, we had this run up
at the beginning of that candle right there, just draw that out in time.
I gave you about 99.95, 99.92 level, okay, that small little range of about three pips.
That's what I was eyeballing last night.
Now I was talking to you, obviously, before midnight.
Now there's things that I teach and have in my repertoire that helps me fine-tune the
low of the day, and I'm not going to teach that here, because I have a community, obviously,
I'm obligated to.
I'm not obligated here, okay, so I don't want you thinking you can guilt me into doing
more than I'm already willing to do, but just know that there's things that I basically
use at my repertoire at midnight that will help me fine-tune the actual low within about
two to three pips, sometimes right on the very low, but it's not needed, okay.
The idea that I just gave on the fly last night when I was doing the commentary was
really simply just rooted on the idea of this extension and ending it right when that candle's
high and just eyeballing it.
So that's what I was looking at.
I expected it to drop down.
I'm not convinced that we're going to see this top yet, so I felt that it dropped down
here, and also being a setup going into London, that's what I would expect, and I'm going
to teach you how to use that information if that's what you want to investigate and study
on your own.
But notice that we ran above these relative vehicle highs, and that's what we ran for
the intraday price action target.
So the high of the day that was set initially around the mid-link time frame, it dropped
down, creating the entire run lower, creating the run in low real close to where I was outlining
it, not exactly, obviously, but it's good enough for government work, and the market
starts to rally and takes out the initial high of the day.
But more specifically, it aims for these really clean levels.
You have this high here, here, and here.
Remember I was teaching just like this level here?
The market does not like to leave that.
That is not efficient.
Now it's efficient for technical analysis, retail 101, where they'll see that as resistance.
It looks perfect.
That's what they want, because the books teach that.
The books are meant to trip you up.
It's flawed logic, folks.
I mean, I hate to say this type of thing to certain individuals because they take aim
at me like I'm trying to belittle everyone else.
It's not that I'm trying to belittle anyone else.
I'm trying to shake you by the lapels and simply say, look, listen to what I'm saying.
Don't believe what I'm saying.
Investigate the things I'm stating in the video.
So that way you can come to your own conclusion.
Either I'm making things up or there's really logic behind it.
And you can dismiss 99.9% of the things out there that everyone looks and relies on having
their charts as far as analysis concepts or indicators.
You don't need all that stuff.
So if I'm suggesting, as I mentioned last night in the video, that we would drop down
here and then start to go higher, that sets the stage for what?
If this is going to be a point at which it reacts and goes higher, as I was outlining
around this time period in the video, that means the opposite should be seen for Euro.
But before we get into that, let's fine tune this a little bit more on a 15 minute time
frame.
You can see we drop down creating the low of the day in London Open.
That's our kill zone that I teach here on the YouTube channel.
It's two o'clock in the morning to five o'clock in the morning, New York local time.
So if you are using the time window thing over here, set it to local New York time,
two o'clock to five o'clock in the morning, that's the kill zone for London Open.
Market comes down, creates the low of the day, runs back up, back into an order block
here.
I'll let you look at the lower time frames and you'll see that is in fact an order block.
And optimal trade entry in the market starts to create its run up into the relative equal
highs, sweeping that as a daily objective.
Now if this is the low of the day and if this is what I've outlined in advance and you've
seen that last night beforehand, this is what I expected to see price drop down in and then
start to go higher.
At the same time, Euro runs all the way back up to the previous week's high.
How is this likely to be a false breakout?
We have to use intermarket relationships like I'm showing you with the dollar index.
So if you're trading Forex, it's important to relate your analysis in the trading market.
For instance, if you're looking at Euro, that's your trading market.
You have to have a barometer, something to measure its movement with and that's intermarket
relationships.
So having that with the dollar, the dollar coming down to a level I outlined last night,
that it would be a bullish area, it would be a sensitive price point to see an advance
higher.
Because it's relationship with Euro, it's inverted.
So if the dollar is going down to that level, that level being 99.92, then it's not a surprise
to see Euro rally higher as it's doing that.
But what is the Euro reaching for?
This high and it went so far as to go up above the previous week's high.
So they really reached up in there, took out the previous week's high and at that same
instance, right there, that's when dollar hit the objective I told you last night, that
would be a buying opportunity for dollar.
If it's a buying opportunity for dollar, then it's a shorting opportunity at that very moment.
Look at your own charts and study the moment it hits this level here, it's the same moment
that the dollar index is hitting that area I was outlining last night for buying opportunity
for dollar.
So this is a false breakout because my analysis was done and shared with you openly that that
would be a buying opportunity for dollar.
Setting the stage for what?
As I outlined, unbearish foreign currency.
Could I have bought that?
Because I'm expecting the dollar index to drop down to that 99.92.
Did I?
No.
I went to sleep.
I was tired.
So I'm not concerned about that.
I didn't take the short either.
I don't care.
I don't want to be in every single move and I'm not trying to trade forex right now.
But to prove to you folks that are sitting out there asking to see if it can be done
in London, does the concepts work?
Can I call a move?
Can I give an idea?
Can I do these things before it happens?
But simply because I can, doesn't obligate me to.
Okay?
I'm not here trying to perform magic tricks for you.
I'm not trying to do that.
I'm trying to teach you to trust your own analysis and lean on your own experience,
even in the early stages when there isn't that much of it.
It's okay.
You learn to grow.
Gradually.
Alright, so the 15 minute time frame.
You can see that the euro went up into its kill zone here, 2 o'clock in the morning,
5 o'clock in the morning, New York Global Time.
So it creates the high of the day.
In this price run, we're going to start stripping it down.
I'm going to make it very easy and not make this video very long.
I'm going to jump right to a very small time frame chart.
Two minute has the very clean fair value gap.
So after it ran above that old weekly high, the market trades lower and takes out that short-term low.
Now, some of you might see this short-term low and say, well, why didn't you use that low instead of this one here?
Well, the reason why is the fair value gap forms right here on this candle.
Once that candle closes, the very next candle, it opens essentially right at that low.
So it hasn't really moved away and hasn't really shown me what?
Displacement, something energetic where it moves away from that fair value gap.
That's the important factor.
So we have the fair value gap here and then it moves lower than that short-term low.
Now we have a shift in market structure.
The market could have came back up into this run here and offered an entry there, but it didn't.
Notice that it went a little bit lower.
That's fine.
And then rallies up to that level here.
This is the entry point.
Now, think about where your stop loss would be and think about where your entry would be based on what I taught you using the New York Session.
This is an opportunity to pause the video and think about it before I show you the annotations.
You're smirking, aren't you, thinking, I'm not pausing it.
So you just might as well get on with it, ICT.
Okay.
So here we have a zoomed in two-minute chart.
And here is the fair value gap level that you would be putting your limit order in.
So it gets filled essentially right there.
Remember, it's not going to be placed in the marketplace for a shorting opportunity or entry on limit anytime in here because it has to move away from the fair value gap.
So it doesn't own this candle here.
So we have that run through this short-term low.
We have displacement.
It was an energetic move lower away from the fair value gap.
It doesn't get to it here.
It goes a little bit deeper.
We wait.
We don't chase it.
We don't go in here thinking, oh, I missed the move.
We still have time.
See all this over here?
The kill zone for London Open is still open.
So we allow for that retracement higher.
Your fill here, maybe one pip at maybe half a pip or maybe a full pip above this candle's high.
That would be your entry.
But we're just going to use the actual candle high.
That would be your limit order entry.
Hypothetically, one point zero nine two four and four pipettes.
That's your entry.
Your stop loss would be above the high here.
That comes in at one point zero nine three six and a half.
And the heat or the drawdown that you absorb hypothetically, if you were to use that entry point, is one point zero nine three zero one.
So basically not even five pips.
Well, about five pips.
Around about five pips of drawdown.
So essentially 25, we'll call it the 30.
So call five pips.
There it is.
Done.
So five pips of drawdown and never came to your stop.
With this gearing, if you use sound money management, how much can you risk if you're risking $1,000 per trade?
OK, you're thinking about money wise.
Don't do that.
You think about it in terms of fixed percentage risk on equity.
So that means you're simply going to look at how much money you have in the account.
Take that times that by one percent.
One percent is the maximum.
Preferably, you should be doing a half of one percent or maybe a quarter of one percent.
You're learning.
You're trying to do a lot in the beginning.
You're trying to just simply trust the idea of seeing these moves.
None of you should be going into demo.
None of you would have done this, obviously, because we're talking about it in hindsight.
But I'm showing you the relationships of how when the market went to this level here and cleared the I stops on the previous high on euro,
that's the very moment that the dollar index went down to the level I outlined.
It would be bullish.
So the teeter totter effect or the inverse relationships that if the dollar is going to go higher,
that means that it's going to have weight introduced to euro and it should start to go lower.
So your entry here and your drawdown and your stop, all those being what they are here,
if we go out a little bit further and I'm just using a five minute chart so I can put everything in the fractal.
In other words, the fractals just move up and then down.
That way you can see it all and have the candles still be clean and have everything on one chart.
So that's the only reason why I'm showing the five minute chart.
I'm not that I'm doing anything special with it.
It's just to show you the overall dynamic of this price run up, the rejection,
the optimal trade entry that would be used with the fair value got used on the two minute time frame,
all the levels and things here being as they were on the two minute chart.
And if you did a Fibonacci run from the low here like this one because it was the most energetic starting this price run here,
that would be your parent price lag. 50% is around in here.
So that would be a nice objective initially. That would be your first target.
If you're going to hold for the full day, it could go down to this area here and lo and behold,
we have that in balance to trade right into that rather handsomely.
So there's your example using it. I gave you the framework beforehand.
I told you what to expect in the dollar index.
And everybody should know that the euro is going to be the opposite direction of whatever the dollar is going to do.
So hopefully this has been insightful to you and you got something out of it.
Until I talk to you next time next week, next Tuesday actually, Lord willing, enjoy your weekend and be safe.